There are two things that I think that great leaders need to have:...
...empathy and perspective.
And I think these things are very often forgotten.
Leaders are so often so concerned about their status or their position in the organization...
...that they actually forget their real job.
And the real job of a leader is not about being in charge.
It's about taking care of those in our charge.
And I don't think people realize this.
And I don't think people train for this.
Leadership is the same.
We all have the capacity to be a leader.
It doesn't mean everybody should be a leader...
...and it doesn't mean everybody wants to be a leader,...
...and the reason is because it comes at great personal sacrifice.
Remember, you're not in charge.
You're responsible for those in your charge.
That means things like when everything goes right, you have to give away all the credit,...
...and when everything goes wrong, you have to take all the responsibility.